In today's video,
we are seeing if it's possible
to carve eggshells using
the acid found in vinegar.
[Music]
Guys, in the previous video,
you saw me dissolve
an eggshell to make
a rubber egg using the acetic
acid found in vinegar.
So today, I want to put
that to the test.
You've probably seen
those really cool eggs
that people carve,
and make really
really pretty designs.
Well, they're beautiful,
but they take a lot of time.
I want to see if we can make
a cheap method today.
Here's the basic idea.
We have three different
substances that should make
egg shells impervious
to the acid found in vinegar.
Let's see if we can carve
patterns on these shells
using these substances.
Now, here's where
this idea came from.
I'm not sure
if you've ever seen that really
easy kids science project
where you use,
basically, a darkly colored soda
and fluoride toothpaste.
Now, what you do is
you coat one side of an egg
with fluoride toothpaste,
and you drop it
into a cup full of soda.
What happens is the egg shell
itself will actually start
to become a muddled brown
or a dark sort of color
where the toothpaste isn't.
The basic idea there is
that it's showing you just
how fluoride protects
the enamel on your teeth,
and what soda can do
to your teeth as well.
So, I want to go ahead and see
if using toothpaste,
we can basically put
a design on to an egg shell,
drop it into some vinegar,
and see if it'll
actually protect it
from the acetic acid
found in it.
There's two other things
I want to try as well,
both a clear nail polish
and a clear acrylic varnish.
Now, the reason why is
because I want to see
if just putting a coating
on the outside of the shell
is going to protect it
from the vinegar.
I'm not sure if it will,
but I wanna find out.
All right, so we've
got our supplies.
We've got our eggs.
Let's go ahead and get started.
So for our first test,
I'm going to go ahead and try
our fluoride toothpaste.
Now, I don't really think,
even using a squeezy tube,
that's going to come
out very pretty.
So we're going to go ahead and
use a dosing syringe to get
that toothpaste into a design
on our egg shell.
That should work.
All right, let's see
if we can make this happen.
Now, normally,
when you carve an egg,
you want it to go
all the way around.
I'm not going to worry
about that today
because I want to be able
to set this down to see
if we can dry just a little.
So, we'll just do
one side of each.
So, anywhere
that our toothpaste,
or our paint,
or our nail polish
is going to be,
that's where, hopefully,
the eggshell will not dissolve.
All right.
Next up, clear nail polish.
Quick drying.
So, for our nail polish,
and our acrylic varnish
or polyurethane varnish,
I'm going to go ahead
and make our designs
a little more intricate
because I'm crossing my fingers
at these might work just
a little bit better,
simply because I'm not sure
our toothpaste is going to dry.
So we're going to go ahead
and leave this one for now.
Start on our acrylic,
and once this is dry, we'll go
ahead and do the other side.
[Music]
All right.
One side on the
acrylic egg done.
So now that our nail
polish egg is dry,
I'm going to go and flip
it over, work on that
while this one dries.
[Music]
So, it is much harder to see
the acrylic paint on this egg,
but that's the point.
By the time everything dries,
and if this works,
I want it to look
like just a regular egg.
So I'm liking the fact
that it's so hard to see.
All right.
So while those dry,
I actually have one other
idea for our eggs.
Now, right here,
I've got an egg
that I hollowed out earlier.
You can see that I've put
little pin holes through it,
and then blown out
all of the guts.
The reason why is
because my hope is
that without the inside,
it may actually allow
the vinegar to seep into it too,
might make it
a little bit easier
for the eggshell to dissolve
wherever I don't have
anything covering it.
Let's see what we can do.
[Music]
While that dries again,
let's go to the next one.
[Music]
I have the nicest
handwriting, guys.
Plain egg, and just within
a couple of seconds,
you can start to see the carbon
dioxide bubbles forming
on the surface of that shell.
Our toothpaste egg,
which is just
a messy nightmare.
Let's be honest here.
Nail polish.
Our regular acrylic paint.
And our hollow egg,
which is only just
occurring to me
that I think it's gonna float.
So, most of this egg is already
covered in acrylic paint.
So I'm just going to make sure
that the part with TKOR is faced down.
Fingers crossed that works.
Oh, yeah,
that's just going
to sit like that.
Now, this is
a good sign already.
You can see
on the nail polish egg
and the acrylic paint egg,
that is solid not hollow,
you can see that
where I've got the acrylic paint
and the nail polish,
the bubbles are forming
around those places.
That's a good sign.
We don't necessarily
need to cover these up,
but it smells a lot
like vinegar in here.
So I'm going to go ahead and
cover the tops with saran wrap.
We'll leave him for 24 hours.
See what happens.
[Music]
All right, guys, so I'm going
to be honest with you.
I left these eggs
over the weekend,
and most of them died.
By died, I mean
that they completely dissolved.
Some of them were
just total messes,
and there wasn't anything left.
So, we started a new batch.
These ones have been
in here about 24 hours.
There were two that I left
because I thought
they were pretty interesting.
The toothpaste egg
and our hollow acrylic egg
did things I wasn't expecting.
So let's go and take
a look at all of these,
and just kind of show you
how these turned out.
You've seen us make a rubber egg
before by dissolving off
the shell using acetic acid
found in vinegar before.
So, this is just
one of those eggs,
and how it's done.
Shell itself is slime, basically.
What you're left with is just
a rubber bouncy egg that you
wouldn't want to bounce,
because it's rotten.
That'd be disgusting.
We have one very,
very squishy egg with almost all
of its shell dissolved.
You can see where it kind
of raised up to the surface.
This part wasn't fully
submerged into vinegar.
But even that would come off
if I just rubbed it enough.
All right, so
our toothpaste egg.
I think there's still
an egg in there.
This actually just ate
all the way through.
Now, it had started to crack
and spider webbed,
and now, the shell is,
it's still there much more
than the other egg shell,
but it's still goofy,
and it could still come off.
So, is toothpaste going to save
an eggshell from acetic acid?
No, it's not.
You can just see the difference.
So we're going to go ahead and
wait on our two painted eggs.
I think these two actually
probably has some good results.
So fingers crossed.
I want to take a look
at our hollow egg real quick
because this one also looked
like it was going to work,
like the toothpaste one.
Now, the toothpaste
one was fascinating
because it held out longer
than the normal plain egg did.
With our hollow egg,
it survived but in
a fascinating way.
I don't even think I can take
this out of the vinegar
because all that's left
right now is the bubble skin.
There's nothing it's
protecting on the inside.
So, while there are some places
that you can see
that the acrylic paint sort
of saved the shell,
I think it actually got inside,
ate up and around in it,
and so now, it's just,
well, it's that.
Yeah, there's vinegar,
and this is what makes me think
that the shelf fully
got eaten through is
because you can actually see
that there's liquid inside.
This was a fully hollow egg.
It just soaked up the vinegar.
The vinegar somehow managed
to get in the egg through
those little tiny pinholes.
I don't even know where,
but the shell itself is just
flaking into pieces
in my hand now.
So, that's really gross.
So first, we'll go ahead
and take a look at our egg
that was painted
with nail polish.
Now, already,
I'm kind of excited
because you can actually see
that the shell is still there,
intact in some places
where I painted it on.
So my hope is that any place
where you can still
see white stripes
where the paint was,
I'm hoping that that is
still solid shell,
so that when we pop it,
and we try and drain
out the egg itself,
that will stay in place.
[Music]
Aha!
So far, so good.
This is hilarious.
The egg,
because the egg was starting
to rot, it's expanded.
So if you get a top down view,
you can actually see
that the egg itself is expanding
from where the shell was,
which means this is going
to smell really great
when I break it open.
Gross.
Gross, gross.
[Music]
Oh my gosh.
It worked.
There you go.
Laser light show egg.
We'll see if we can carve
out that lining.
See if we could just get
that shell like we want.
Yes, in case you're wondering,
the entire studio smells
like rotten egg and vinegar.
A carved egg using
nail polish and acid.
Let's take a look
at our polyurethane paint egg.
Hopefully, it'll pour
out just as easy.
I'm a little bit more concerned.
If you take a look
at this one, you'll notice
that it doesn't look
like the acetic acid is eaten
through as much of the shell.
Also, there seems
to be some cracks up
at the top on one side.
I'm just very glad
that Nate isn't in
the studio today.
He's not trying to eat
anything right now.
This one did not survive nearly
as well as the nail polish egg.
You can actually see the cracks
running through the shell.
It still feels pretty stable.
I still want to try though.
It did eat through the sides.
I don't know
if it's going to work as well,
but let's find out.
Okay.
Well, so far so good.
Similar results.
You can definitely see
that some of these sides
did not hold up as well.
But they're still there.
Already lost that one
side right there.
So I'm not even going
to finish trying.
I am going to try
and peel out that lining
because the nail polish egg
did survive me pulling
out the lining.
This one, just me trying
to slice through isn't working.
If I pull it out,
I have a feeling this whole
thing's going to crumble.
But let's see.
[Music]
As I'm working,
the whole egg
is just crumbling.
So I think that's as good as
we're gonna get with regular,
just clear acrylic paint.
However, compared to
our fully hollow egg,
we're still doing better.
So, comparison time.
We've got our fresh regular egg,
we've got our control
test plain egg,
and egg with toothpaste,
and the egg with acrylic paint,
a hollow acrylic paint egg,
and then, shockingly to me,
the nail polish egg.
That's the one that survived,
and now, obviously,
I was just going for a very
quick and easy design.
Something that I thought
would structurally hold up,
which it obviously did.
But if you wanted
to spend some time,
even with another sort
of clear nail polish,
and really put in some detail,
you can carve an egg
without having to do much work.
All I got to do is paint it, put
it in some vinegar overnight.
[Music]
Hey guys, thanks for watching.
Click up there if you want
to see our last video,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.